coleman hughes is an accomplished writer
a philosophy graduate and the host of
the podcast conversations with coleman a
link to which is in the description
coleman sat down with me for a podcast
on consciousness uaps and theoretical
physics though because of certain
technical issues this is being released
on the toe podcast instead of on his
platform a much longer follow-up is
going to be conducted over zoom for his
channel comment with any questions that
you feel were left unanswered or areas
that you would like to be explored more
and coleman will try to address them for
the follow-up next week on the toe
channel will be professor abbay ashtakar
who is a prestigious and acclaimed
physicist who paved the way for modern
quantum gravity approaches like loop
quantum gravity and loop quantum
cosmology he talks about what occurred
prior to the big bang i'm sure you heard
that nothing existed prior to the big
bang well that's only true in certain
models they're cyclical models where
that's not true in loop quantum
cosmology there is no singularity but
instead a repulsive force that breeds
another universe under certain
conditions ashtakar is the physicist
referenced numerously in a positive
light by salvatore pius in fact sal sent
in a question for ashtakar on the super
force expect that in about a week's time
as mentioned before this is a brand new
season for the theories of everything
project or channel where i'm going to
explore different kinds of content so
for example new guests that aren't
repeatedly interviewed on the standard
podcast rolodex like ashtakar for
example there will be more theolocutions
such as one that's coming up is bernardo
castro and chris langan there will be
other explainer type videos so for
example how does one go about learning a
new theory of everything and some
ancillary content like an inventorying
video about new creators up and coming
creators in the uap physics math
consciousness space as tiny creators
tend to get overlooked despite toiling
just as hard and given the modest
following on this channel it would be
great to shine some light their way as i
know i wish someone larger had done that
for me when i was struggling no sponsor
for today's podcast if you'd like to
contribute then do consider going to
patreon.com that is c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l as this is what i'm
able to do full-time now thanks to your
generous support
enjoy coleman hughes interviewing kurt
jaymungal all right kurt thanks so much
for coming on my show yeah thank you
thank you for inviting me so i've been
listening to your podcasts theories of
everything right right and we're gonna
get into the topics you cover
but before we do that can you give a
little summary of who you are where
you're from
you know your background how you came to
care about topics
like
you know ufos and
and
consciousness and physics and so forth
right so my name is kurt jaymungal and
i've
been interested in
what are called theories of everything
since i was a child
since i learned about them so you've
heard i'm sure you've heard there's
quantum mechanics technically it should
be quantum field theory and then general
relativity some people say it's the
theory of the small with the theory of
the large
technically elephants are quantum
mechanical so it's a bit strange to
relegate quantum mechanics to just the
small
so if we did enough experiments and we
took an elephant and we threw it through
a double slit
it should
in theory
split regardless when i was small i
heard about this
it's a contradiction or it's a
difficulty in putting these two
pieces together and one needs to in
order to be able to describe black holes
and what happened at the origin of the
universe so there are various mysteries
in physics
and i've been interested in that since
as far as i can remember
then i did my undergraduate in something
called mathematical physics then i went
into filmmaking
and somewhat abandoned that though i
kept the same
state of mind when i approached
filmmaking
and then since the pandemic started i
thought you know what why not just
go back to these roots i'm super
interested in i think about it almost
all the time
it unhinges me to some degree but anyway
i think about it
almost every minute or so so i started
interviewing people about their theory
of everything so their combination of
quantum mechanics and general relativity
then i found out that there's more than
just that because there's the mystery of
well what the heck is consciousness and
what role does it play fundamentally
does it emerge from what we think of as
material so dead matter
and it's somehow it became successful
and that's now i'm super lucky much like
yourself i'm sure you're like holy moly
i get to do it to talk to awesome people
because i see what you want to talk to
yeah and i got to think about stuff that
i think about
you know regardless
it's almost like we're
researchers
but in the university except we're not
being paid by the university and we
don't have to
conform to whatever the university wants
us to do
you know universities
i
at columbia i struggled to get the kind
of
deep and free thought that i actually
wanted to live by
in a classroom setting it was a rare
professor that would set
the culture of the class
freely enough that we could really
really pursue
the the the deepest
consequences of the ideas in the room
with no fear with no social fears so
that is basically
i think the the
the the places
that actually allow for truly free
thought
which is supposed to be what a
university is have shifted in some ways
to places like
you know my podcast your podcast and and
other places in the culture have sort of
filled that vacuum
yeah yeah it's
it's it's wonderful well it's wonderful
for us it's not wonderful for
the universities though they
i think they think it is it's it's for
their net benefit right
at least they claim to
and i'm also from toronto so that's the
reason why there's a background we
switched backgrounds earlier oh yeah
yeah no i i was there and i said that's
your domain i'm right here yeah yeah
new york is much like so this is my
first time in new york and toronto kind
of look like yes yeah yeah new york is
far greater i've only been to toronto
for like two hours
three hours but i remember thinking
this is eerily similar to new york it's
a moderately cleaner new york and a hey
drastic than a drastically smaller new
york
well i guess
the two major topics i want to talk to
you about
are ufos
or or uaps as they're now called
and consciousness sure
so which order do you want to take these
in maybe maybe let's start with ufos oh
sure sure
uh
and this is a you know for anyone
interested in this topic your your
podcast
is a major resource because you've
talked to so many different people
uh
about this topic
and
i've i don't think i've ever talked
about this on my podcast but
basically what i believe has happened is
three to four years ago
ufos were a topic that
marked you as crazy
and
really
anyone interested in them would be
dismissed
and the reason they would be dismissed
is because people like me who weren't
deeply into the topic
you know i'd seen the videos of
things that looked essentially like
flying saucers
caught on cameras
on youtube and elsewhere
but
because the the the us government had
never
given a rubber stamp to these
videos
what i think many people assumed was
that there must be some other
explanation
that
folks high up
uh
believes as for for example that
the camera was glitching out or that it
it wasn't actually an aircraft it was
something else that just looks like an
aircraft some atmospheric effects some
atmosphere yeah like a rare event of
ball lightning right ball lightning or
whatever and
uh or or it's
or it's a us military
actually a us military device that the
government is keeping secret it was a
military test or it was russian or
chinese
and we just i just assumed whatever the
explanation is
you know the people at the pentagon have
it
and they haven't talked about it because
it's it's a state secret
and um and on the tinfoil hat crowd on
the internet is is reading into it
uh
and then
you know in the past two years
that whole
uh
type of dismissal is no longer really
possible to make
because
uh
you know
the the videos especially the ones from
the navy
there are at least three different
videos i've seen that have been released
that were taken by navy
pilots
aircrafts where they're seeing something
that looks
you know exactly like our stereotype of
a ufo and they're saying
what the [ __ ] is this
and then
you know our folks
at the us government have looked at it
every which way and their conclusion is
what the [ __ ] is this right they they
they are as confused and interested as
people i would have dismissed three
years ago as a as the conspiracy
theorist and the alien obsessives right
so that's basically
that's sort of the c shift as i see it
is that how you see it yeah except i
wouldn't say that the shift is such that
if you were to talk about it you're not
deemed to be a loon of some sort there
are still people like bill nye and neil
degrasse tyson and michael shermer who
either explicitly state that if you're
jumping to the conclusion that this
isn't a terrestrial phenomenon
then you're insensate and you should be
following only what where the evidence
leads you
so and there's compilations of this so
for example
i recently requested someone to come up
with a compilation of this because i
didn't see the exact words for a while
i've just heard that people like neil
degrasse tyson etc have
despised the ufo community anyway
there's this
twitter account named tupac cabra
ii so tupac cobra number two and he
released this whole clip so people can
watch then see that yes there is a shift
it seems to be in the general population
but in the people who are the supposedly
the purveyors of rational scientific
mindsets they tend to still dis esteem
yeah so i i'm not
so so
there's one question which is
are ufos real
as in unidentified flying objects are
they really ufos are they really
you know now they call them unidentified
aerial phenomena because
precisely because they are real and
don't don't want to give them the sort
of stigma of the phrase ufo
so there's that we know they're real at
this point
essentially i mean
all the evidence points that way
everyone
seems to think that very credible people
from barack obama to right you know john
brennan
think this that they're real and then
there's the the further question of what
they are right where they're from and
that seems to me still unanswered
but the the likelihood that it is they
they are extraterrestrial
epistemically i think that's gone up for
me
in the past two years i i wouldn't
venture to say it's anything close to a
certainty or anything
like that but
it becomes
harder and harder to believe that
these are you know made
on earth
and um
and less and less crazy to
to put into the ring the hypothesis that
they are from extraterrestrials so i
mean how convinced are you at this point
that
the ufos that we've seen on from the
navy videos and so forth
are extraterrestrial in origin no one
piece of evidence of someone may say
well what evidence exists
and
well
that's a tough question no one piece of
evidence is what convinces me and i'm
also in a similar position where i'm
i remain unconvinced as to any specific
explanation is it something that's
related to
a being or beings from other places
coming toward earth that aren't
originated on earth some hypothesis some
hypotheses are that
they're future humans coming back for
some reason so they're closed time-like
curves in physics you may call it that
and i don't know about that because
there are some contradictions with
closed timeline curves but it seems like
the standard response is hey we see some
object in the sky it's called u-f-o or
u-a-p for a reason it's unidentified to
make the leap that therefore aliens is a
is a large leap and that's true however
and that's what i hear neil degrasse
tyson etc and i keep picking on him but
it's a bit unfair for me to do so
he's the poster child of this so let me
just use him as a scapegoat for now
so people like neil degrasse tyson would
say that yeah that's that's a
unscientific leap however it's not
simply that we see some objects in the
sky and then we say it's aliens it's
that there's a variety of correlations
with them so they're correlated you see
some object in the sky then you see
cattle mutilations directly afterward
and no single person see for crop
circles there have been people who have
been caught and there are
hundreds if not thousands of cattle
mutilations which where
cows are drained of blood
and investigated with surgeon-like
precision with lasers and so on it seems
like laser cuts certain organs are
removed
in a manner that vets don't know how the
heck that could be explained and that's
seen
close to before or after or during
these cattle mutilation the
objects in the sky so that's one
correlation another one is that then
there's also people who report
being spoken to by these means or seeing
them then there's also the correlation
that and these are also disparate people
so people who could not have come in
contact with one another so someone
let's say
thinks they were abducted
and
someone else from far away also saw a
craft and these two people have not
communicated so you can't simply say
it's mass hallucination and by the way
this term mass hallucination it's not a
scientific term because in order for it
to be a scientific construct it needs to
be a reliable one that can be repeated
but the mass hallucinations aren't in
fact i was speaking to someone not on
the podcast over email about this term
someone who studies mass hallucinations
he doesn't think it actually happens he
thinks that
well we can get into that later yeah so
i just wanna so i i know less i haven't
looked deeply into the phenom phenomenon
you're talking about i've looked into
ufos and uads and i've heard
sorry
ufo and uaps but but the the cattle
mutilations and
the you know the injuries
that people think couldn't
can't be man-made injuries
this is something it's it's very hard
for me to know what to think about this
because
um
you know they're i'm just aware of how
many hoaxes there are in the world
and i'm i'm
i'm also aware of the phenomenon of
social contagion which i'm you're
talking about mass hallucinations
which
you know i i think i actually
do believe in in mass hallucinations in
the sense of you know we know that there
are
many examples through throughout history
and in the present of social contagion
phenomenon
where
you know an idea
sort of just travels from one person to
the next without real basis right it's
like the the school
that where everyone you know like half
the school got hiccups
um a few years ago
and it was it was a social like they
didn't all get chronic hiccups there was
just this
kind of brain worm that leapt from
person to person
um you know recently there was an
atlantic article about people on
tick-tock
getting tourettes especially girls
did you see this i heard about this yes
like they don't have they don't
their tourette's is caused by the
psychology of
you know subconsciously admiring other
tourette's tick-tock influencers and
you know without really
consciously trying to adopting the
symptomology of of tourette's
without the actually uh the actual
underlying
sort of typical tourette's condition and
when
you know it's it's really no stranger
than than the placebo effect it's like
why do we
why do we actually have symptoms when we
take a sugar pill that's actually deeply
strange
how how much
psychology and and suggestion
right can actually influence your real
experience
so
being
very interested in social contagion
phenomena
phenomena
um
i i'm less skeptical than you are of the
possibility that many of these
uh many
of these sightings are
uh you know people that have
they've seen movies or they've they've
heard things about ufo and and
it gets sort of reproduced for them in
what they see i'm not saying that is
what it is i'm saying i don't dismiss
that possibility
yeah
yeah so that
can exist for
i i don't like to put numbers on it but
let's imagine it's 90
and then i don't like to say that well
who knows well then the remaining 10
well that's still extraordinary well
that remaining 10 could still be
explained with
i
i don't know if it could still be
explained because like i mentioned
there's independent verification so
someone saw a craft from far away
and then someone else saw
another craft and they
are extremely similar in their
descriptions and this happens
with people who we would consider to be
highly credible in any other situation
in such a manner that if
we were to have a court of law and
sentence someone to
sometimes even death for murdering
someone because you had a set of
witnesses but without any physical
evidence i don't think that would be the
case in capital punishment but
for putting someone to prison
a variety of corroborating witnesses of
a certain credibility would be
sufficient to send someone to the
jailhouse for
an indeterminate amount of time we then
don't believe these people
who study crafts people are pilots
themselves
who have seen them maneuver in the same
way that's another correlation it's not
like they just maneuver
in a variable manner there's some
uncertainty to how they move but it's
also still correlated like they move in
a
in such a manner that you would say okay
that's like a ufo whereas one that goes
in
i guess in a figure eight you would say
that's odd i wouldn't classify that you
mentioned earlier what's behind the ufos
are real that's interesting
what makes something real is it when
see in physics if you had an unknown
particle an unidentified particle
so we don't know what this particle is
but then you see how it behaves with
other particles so you see it's
correlation you would need six sigma so
extreme amount of data in order for you
to call it a particle anyway for you to
give it a name but the general idea is
that you have a variety of correlations
then you
classify it as quote unquote real or a
construct in social sciences that bar is
much lower i believe it's something like
five percent
uncertainty and what i'm telling you
about here is that there's the
correlation of also certain damage to
people who are close to the craft that
are all similar the hitchhiker effect
which means that certain
quote unquote
paranormal phenomenon follow these
people afterward and not these aren't
people who
are necessarily spiritual or religious
so that's like absolutely freaky that's
why
i've had to take a break from studying
this
phenomenon by the way it's called the
phenomenon because it's not just
relegated to alien life it seems to be
blurred in some manner
i had to take a break from studying
consciousness in this and this
phenomenon because it's it's it's
extremely destabilizing
i have such uncertainty in my world
view
that
that i'm
somewhat adrift whenever i study these
topics
and and it's not a pleasant place at all
it's this is extremely not pleasant
so
it sounds like uh
you might need to change a profession
yeah or at least a strong break or
change your
topic on your podcast so mathematics and
physics
calms me
to such a large degree because it's so
analytical
and so i've been studying math and
physics
lately for the podcast okay podcast
again it's about theories of everything
which is a physics terminology but then
i'm interested in consciousness because
it may have a
constitutive role to play in reality so
there's something called idealism most
scientists
think of themselves as materialists
i'm sure you've heard this term i'm sure
your audience has heard of this term
and then someone to the opposite end of
materialism some materialism says that
it's something like dead matter that
makes up the world and then
consciousness is a phenom an
epiphenomenon that occurs atop from
information processing
it seems to be information processing
that's the consensus
the other side is idealism which says
that consciousness is fundamental
consciousness is actually
what is at the root it's not
consciousness that needs to be explained
it's material that needs to be explained
and if so then all of these
phenomena that you mentioned like the
placebo effect makes sense and this is
another reason why i don't condescend or
despise people who are religious
i i used to man i used to be a militant
atheist up until about three years ago
or so i'm so much more open to god
and to religious stories as having an
element of literal truth to them not
just metaphorical truth
i don't see it as so strange that
there's some
being that out of love maybe and maybe
that's a bit
woo but some being that created this
world created us
i don't see that as being so far-fetched
as much as i used to
and so
i also don't know
this is another odd aspect i don't also
don't know how much of
god becomes true because we believe in
god that the fact that we believe in
something makes it exist because
consciousness and our beliefs have a
constitutive role to play in what we
call reality
i don't see that as being as far-fetched
as
it's so difficult because the question
is well what is reality and how do you
make sense of
that without making a further assumption
so physicalists which are on par with
materialists will say that
well what's the evidence that
consciousness is fundamental well
firstly what's the evidence that
material is fundamental science as an
enterprise is agnostic philosophically
people like to think that it's a
materialistic
base that has materialism at its base
but it's more instrumental it's more
like if-then statements
we measure this if you do this you then
see this it doesn't say that what's at
the bottom is dead matter because in
order for you to say what's dead you
have to say what's alive and
what's life and what's consciousness is
also a bleary category and so you can't
make an a blurry category and pretend
that that's
a valid construct almost like yeah okay
i'm afraid we're going to lose people i
want to go back to the sort of
root problem of consciousness
um and and try to convey it
how i see it in simple terms and maybe
you can tell me if you see it the same
way
[Music]
basically
we have every reason to believe that
the atoms in our brain
are
are are no different than the atoms in
this chair
or in my appendix
or in you know the oxygen in this room
and yet we know that there's something
it's like to be this brain
right like there's there's
there's a first person experience to be
had
you know when atoms are assembled
in such a way as to create a human brain
and
we're not so sure that there's something
it's like when atoms are
comprised so as to make this chair
maybe maybe there is but but we we tend
to think that there isn't
and so the question is
how come
when you put atoms together in this way
suddenly there's something it's like to
be that entity
um versus when you put
the same atoms together in a different
configuration there's nothing it's like
to be that entity now the question might
be framed the wrong way but that that to
me is is like the
the basic puzzle how come my appendix
doesn't have an
identity might be too strong a word but
an experience right
from its point of view the way that my
like what's special about the meat in in
the skull it's just meat
right
yeah
well i i don't know do you see it that
way or no no i don't know if
an appendix
has a point of view it may have some low
level point of view if one was to
believe
the majority of these
theories on consciousness which you
mentioned the word first person and
third person we can get to them
which try to study consciousness from a
third person point of view
it seems as though they're
if you follow them and you take them
seriously they're panned psychic
because in some sense this is
interacting with this chair
what what's interacting with this the
atoms here are interacting with the
chairs so firstly
our atoms are not separate they're
overlapping
in
quantum mechanically they're overlapping
so to say that there's a difference
between this chair and this chair that's
a human construct
and when i say human construct i sound
like a postmodernist
but what i mean is
these words that we're using like first
person third person what it's like to be
quote unquote firstly that's another
synonym for consciousness which we're
trying to define so we then define
consciousness in terms of something else
which we don't understand so we say if
there's an experience of what it's like
what does it mean what it's like and
then we get into a circular definition
of consciousness it may be just that our
words are not developed enough
to capture what consciousness is
it may be that again consciousness is
fundamental so trying to place it in
terms of something that's immaterial
like you mentioned atoms and a kidney
and so on is a wrong
frame to begin with much like asking
how can one make gold out of silver or
silver out of gold before understanding
about nuclear reactions it's it's you
just can't do it it's a chemical
reaction can't do it
so it may be that that's the wrong frame
and we keep thinking that it's the right
frame and then we get into paradoxes
or antinomies like the
hard problem of consciousness
it's a hard problem if one starts with
thinking of the world comprising dead
matter
and it's unclear to me whether or not
our kidneys have
some low grade consciousness so there's
the integrated information theory of
intelligence sorry of consciousness
there's global neuronal workspace
there's spacio temporal
theories of consciousness
adverbial consciousness theories
and
all of these are about matter
interacting with one another and so
there's matter interacting with itself
in our kidney and so that would mean
that
in some sense
the universe has some low level
consciousness
and the developers of iit like tanoni
have
conceded in a sense that
yes this is
rational
psychism so is panza is pan psychism
um is that everything has some element
of a psychic quality some element of
consciousness correct right so as i said
pan psychism is not it's not really
testable is it nor are almost any
theories about the origin of
consciousness is materialism
right right so so i have
i'm i'm like totally agnostic between
materialist explanations of of
consciousness and and pan psychist
explanations and and in fact
i'm i'm pretty convinced of colin
mcginn's
idea the philosopher column again
which is some kind sometimes called
mysterian
mysterianism
as well oh is that is that right yeah
yeah which is um
you know which you've had chomsky on so
i'm sure you know but for for the
audience
essentially
the point is
human beings were not evolved to
understand
everything in the world it's like
we were evolved to survive and reproduce
on the african savanna
so
we're we're very good at predicting
you know when an object is thrown in the
air that it's going to fall in a
parabolic shape right because that's
that's very that was very useful to us
we're very um
you know there's all kinds of things
we're quite good at we're good at fairly
good at understanding someone else's
intentions like i see a guy with an
angry face going to hit me i can tell
that apart from a guy with a friendly
face
our brains are are built
to solve
all and
only problems that relate
are optimized for that goal of survival
and reproduction in a particular
environment
and
you know just like every other animal in
the in the animal kingdom has
limits to what it can understand
right it's like we we
we understand i can do algebra but but i
can see that a chimp could never
in principle even understand
really algebra
at all
what does it stand to reason that just
because we happen to be the smartest
animals that we know about that there
isn't a whole landscape of
problems
that we stand in relation to the way a
chimpanzee stands in relation to algebra
or i mean the example i i like to use is
more like
an animal that can't understand that its
reflection in a mirror is
itself rather than another animal
um
it's like a a chicken is never in a
million years going to understand that
light can come back
at you the concept of reflection is just
constantly permanently
yeah it's just like it's never going to
get that
it's if it could speak
if we could hear its thoughts when it's
looking at itself in the mirror it would
just be
like a functional yeah and it would be
wait a minute how come this chicken
every time i move it moves and then it
would come up with a whole bunch of
theories much like we do about
consciousness
that none of which actually deeply makes
sense or are satisfying to the chicken
and it would just have to sort of throw
throw its hands up
in in a deep way which is to say there's
lots of mysteries that we've solved like
it's a mystery for 100 years and then we
figure it out
right but there are mysteries that i
believe there are mysteries
that are in principle unsolvable
by beings like us by apes like ourselves
because
they are beyond our ken in the same way
that reflection is beyond the kind of
many animals and it consciousness
strikes me as as precisely this kind of
mystery yeah i oscillate between
that view and also the view of
some people like
so yoshobak likes to say mysterianism is
the philosophical view that unless
there's
that someone as smart as noam chomsky
can't figure it out therefore we can't
all figure it out
so he likes to denigrate chomsky and
just poke and jab him
a bit i'm trying to set up a talk
between them too between the two of them
on the toe channel toes for theories of
everything regardless i oscillate
between
between thinking it's completely out of
our comprehension just because we're
such limited beings
and also
i actually oscillate between that and
then there's some remarks from
wittgenstein
i think they're called his clarificatory
remarks at least simon christian calls
him that where he said
that
there are aspects of life and he was
referring to consciousness i believe
that are
most important but hidden to us because
of their simplicity and familiarity
much like a fish
doesn't think about water but it's
if it could it would realize it's right
there
there's john wheeler who also said
behind this all maybe an idea that's so
beautiful and simple
that when we finally
comprehended
a decade a century millennia from now
we will all look at one another and
think
how could it have been any other way and
how could we have been so foolish
not to see it so i don't know and some
of the people who are on the more
eastern end think that it
is what needs the least explaining
consciousness is what's closest to us
it's every single thing else that needs
explaining
someone like what does that actually
mean though what was how does that
actually
answer the question of
you know why
why the meat in my head is conscious and
you know other collections of atoms
aren't the way that
one does that is by questioning that
assumption that one starts with all that
you know is of consciousness actually
that's your fundamental
that you're that's at the fundament
that's at the base is consciousness and
so when we say well we're trying to
explain consciousness what is
consciousness it's no what is anything
else everything starts with
consciousness i mean i understand the
concept of just reversing
the question
but that doesn't it doesn't strike me as
any
that explanation doesn't strike me as
any
more satisfying
than
the the materialist explanation which is
well it's just
information processing and
um but we're also kind of not sure why
computers aren't conscious even though
they process information it's like
that
those two leave me equally unsatisfied i
think because
simply reversing the question without
giving me a reason to accept that
framework over others
when it's not obvious it
also
just doesn't really quench my thirst
on on the questions if that makes sense
yeah
bernardo castro is someone who is a
proponent of what's called analytic
idealism and he would say
that
materialists have developed
what's called an ontological category
which simple ontologist just means what
is and then category is hopefully we're
familiar with what a category is
by saying that there's material because
what we do is we
start with consciousness as our first
person experience that is not what needs
explaining and then
what we've done as materialists is say
that there exists something else
when there's no need for that science
can exist
in its exact same form
without having to
posit an entirely new
quote-unquote ontological category
of
dead
i'm just going to say dead matter
unconscious matter
so it's it's strange that that was the
leap that was made now i'll give you
another i understand what you're saying
because i also too oscillate between
whether it's a satisfying explanation
that's a great question what the heck is
an explanation at what point do we say
okay so-and-so has been explained
i'll give you i'll give you a quick
sorry but to go back on that it's like
when
when you see somebody
die or or you know you fall into a
dreamless sleep
you experience the lights going out at
least in the second case
and it very much looks like the lights
going out when somebody dies
right and and so
our intuition
that
there is conscious matter and
unconscious matter
is
is not
i mean it's it's not crazy it's it's
like we we are
we are trying to make sense of the fact
that sometimes the lights go out for us
when we have a dreamless sleep
and it certainly looks like the lights
are going out for for people and animals
when they die
and so we're trying you know it it does
seem like the universe has
two things to exp you know two
states right like conscious matter and
and what you're calling dead matter
um so why is it why is it wrong to view
that
data as the the total phenomenon to be
explained
i'm not saying it's wrong i don't know
but another point of view is that when
we have sleep
we don't experience the lights going out
we think by definition
because there's no experience we don't
know
this is something else this is something
that we project onto the experience of
sleep so here's something to think about
can you ever experience non-experience
no again by definition right so then we
think
that there's this gap in our
consciousness what we've done is we've
seen other people and we've
come up with this category of
non-consciousness and then we
confabulate that back to ourselves but
as a matter of experience we never
experience quote-unquote the lights
going out because by definition you
can't so it's
it should be i don't see why
it isn't a continuous a continuum
between sleep and wake
now it may feel
because you're constantly experiencing
there's no such thing as non-experience
as you experiencing non-experience when
we say hey we
i didn't experience
well
yes but then you're projecting some
notion of time and so on but as a matter
of experience and remember the idea is
start with experience as a matter of
experience there's no gap in your
experience because there can't be
because as
because by definition okay so you
understand that so then when we say well
someone so died we don't know in a
strange sense it's like
in a strange sense
life is not what needs explaining
because that's what comes that's what we
see first it's it's death and this is
actually extremely freaky because i
don't want to
part of me doesn't want to believe in
life after death life after what we
think of as death
because it was disconcerting to me i i
find the materialist's point of view to
be much more
comforting
personally but regardless it's
we don't know what the heck happened to
that person and then we start we start
to project some of what we think is
happening back to ourselves but as a
matter of experience we don't experience
death nor life sorry nor sleep there's
no gap in experience
so as a matter of experience
death is
something we don't know we're just
making some category up and then we're
saying it applies
but we we as
we don't have
any data points for that
we don't have any observations of what
it's like to not have an observation
right i get that that's
that has to be true by definition
but um
so like when i see someone go to sleep
i see that their all of their behavior
stops essentially except for breathing
and
you know i i assume
for the most part maybe they're having a
dream experience because i've had and
remembered many dream experiences
but i don't have that every night you
know presumably you know it's possible
i've had many dreams that that i just
don't remember
and this this goes to your point of
having an experience but not remembering
it
uh feels the same in retrospect as not
having had an experience at all it's
like if i if for some reason i just
was like fully blackout drunk
last night like perfectly blackout drunk
for an hour
then
remembering last night to me it's the
same as if i was if as if i was having
no experience at all
right as if i was in a dreamless sleep
for that hour
um and i i would have no way of really
telling those apart other from the other
than the sort of context clues of the
rest of the day like oh i went out last
night i must have gotten blackout drunk
i understand what you're saying um so
there's yeah there's no difference
between having an experience with no
memory and not having an experience when
you're looking back on it for sure
but um
i mean i i guess we we make inferences
on what's likely to be true from not
only from our first person from adding
our first person experience to our
observations of others and patterns in
the world so like one
pattern
or
imperfect
but but frequently found correlation in
the world is that
um
when people are
exhibiting behaviors like talking and
standing and walking and so forth
they're also they also tend to be
experiencing
something and and we find this in our
own lives and it seems to be true
of others
that there is um a connection between
you know
behavior
and doing things and having blood flow
to your brain
and feeling things
from the inside
so we assume when all the behavior stops
and the blood stops flowing and all of
the mechanics
just grind to a halt
that that's the end of experience
because those two variables tend to be
correlated now the the problem with that
is we we have examples where they're
totally not correlated such as
locked-in syndrome
which is
where you know a person is in a hospital
bed
totally pretty much totally immobile
comatose for all we can tell
and only when they wake up from the coma
do we discover
they were hearing and seeing the whole
time right it's like the
the sort of um
[Music]
i guess was was was kill bill sort of
like this like uma thurman and kill bill
i could be misremembering that movie but
my memory she you know she was in a coma
and the doctor
basically raped her
and she but she was actually conscious
the whole time yeah and then she [ __ ]
him up when she got out of the coma it
was just this great moment
but like the fact that that's possible
means that there isn't actually
an 100
connection between
uh behavior and consciousness
it's like you can be conscious and
look and be comatose
and um
and so and and not only that but you can
get complex behavior
without what seems to be consciousness
it's like i i talked to anika harris
about this and in her book she was
she gave these examples of of
extraordinary extraordinarily complex
behavior by networks of trees
communicating underground and stuff and
like
wait a minute so they're communicating
they're communicating like that's a
behavior we would normally associate
with consciousness
and it's they're not built they're
they're natural right they're they're
communicating but we assume that they're
not conscious
so the
you can get behavior without
consciousness consciousness without
complex behavior even though those two
things tend to be correlated most of the
time
[Music]
and
and what's more it doesn't seem like
there's a logical reason why
consciousness would have to accompany
complex behavior
right like from the point of view of
darwinian evolution
why does it matter
that
there's something it's like to be
one of these survival machines it's like
my appendix doesn't
you know wouldn't need to feel what it's
doing
that's a bad example since the appendix
is pointless my kidneys
wouldn't need to feel what it's doing in
order to serve their purpose
you know
for my survival
how how come
certain aspects of my body i'm conscious
of
but others i'm just not it's like what
is the what's the evolutionary rationale
for
some of these things
being accompanied by
my experiencing them and others just
being totally like i wouldn't even know
i had half the organs in my body if i
if i didn't take a biology class
so that's
part of the mystery too
i understand
there's a couple terms you use there
which is third person
a couple others that i can't recall and
you which is another one so firstly the
category of you so someone else
oh this is where it gets extremely
tricky for me psychologically but anyway
we can talk about that another time
the
one has to think about what constitutes
evidence so as evidence
when you say sorry i don't mean to see
you like i'm accusing you when one says
let's say when one says i watch someone
sleep
and the lights went out for them it's as
if they're well firstly that's a bit
creepy one
periodically watch people sleep
it's as if they're projecting and i keep
using this word projecting because i
don't have another
term to use
god's eye view
where we have this
where we imagine time ticking in this
fashion
and then
we imagine that they're not experiencing
anything well we can ask them afterwards
do you remember so and so
and then we say there was a gap and so
we imagine that that gap occurs for us
but as a matter of evidence for us we
don't have that and so from their point
of view there was no gap and from our
point of view we never have a gap
and so what i'm saying is that we then
project what we think of as a gap from
them onto us because we imagine we're so
great at doing this because of the
development of science of thinking of
of
the world from a third person point of
view like a god's eye view that this is
all just ticking clocks and billiard
balls bouncing off one another and yes
there's some complexities with
qft and so on quantum quantum mechanics
and so on so it's already making a leap
and i'm saying that the people who are
idealists say there's no need to make
that leap
continue with the first person that's
where you start and that's where you can
end you start to develop other points of
view but then
but then paradoxes come in well well
so i guess um
the first person doesn't answer
the question either way so it's like i i
fall asleep
i i and then i wake up
my first
if i'm solely going by my first person
experience
i've got no idea what happened
right
i i don't know
whether i blacked out
and wha actually had an experience that
i'm simply now not remembering
sort of like the show severance i don't
know if you you've checked now it's this
great show
um amazing really really worth worth
watching and maybe even worth worth
talking about on on your podcast
where people undergo a sci-fi
they don't explain how the procedure is
done but they undergo a procedure
where
their their memory is spatially
uh
bound which means they go to work
and
when they enter the door to work
they no longer remember anything about
their their life outside of that
building right okay it's like they're so
they only remember memories that they
have made in in this space they exit now
they only
remember memories they have made in the
outside world yeah so it's a way of
completely psychologically
severing your work life and your home
life
and
and what's interesting what's
interesting about it is
the moment
you know what they've essentially done
is created two different people
i mean in some ways in some ways they've
created two different people and in some
ways they're the same person because
they're basically
you know the the
what the home life person experiences
is
going to work today going to work
the moment they walk through the door
they walk out
right it's like it's like going to sleep
and waking up and and and their the work
version of them experiences the same
thing they're just at work they're this
person feels like he is at work his
whole life
right because the second he goes home
he's walking through the door again like
waking up
and so there's essentially two people
that feel like they're living their
entire lives on opposite ends of this
thing and from their first person
experience
uh you know they they have no idea
what's happening when they walk through
that door they
for all they know they're just
nothing happens at all
um or they for all they know they're
they've been outside for a year and all
they have to go by is like
sort of how their body feels
when they walk back through the door
it's like if they're exhausted they
assume something must have happened
out there or if they if they've got a
cut they assume that they they have to
have gotten that cut
at work
um are they aware that they're losing
like in memento the guy is aware
that he has memory lapses yeah yeah yeah
they're they're aware they signed up for
this procedure um
okay the reason why i was saying don't
mean to drop the reason why i was saying
there are a couple delusive concepts
there so the third person like i
mentioned well if we're idealist let's
just abandon that it doesn't mean that
other minds don't exist it just means in
terms of evidence stick with yourself
okay then there's also the well my
reaction was that that doesn't answer
the questions necessarily okay well
we'll get back to that because there's
also the concept of you which implies a
continuous identity and that's a
delusive concept because it's not clear
so are you the same you as you were
yesterday and so on and so on and then
can you experience without having memory
so when you go to sleep is it the case
that
people are experiencing something
somewhere maybe this
nullity void that the buddhists say is a
place of nothingness
and then you come back but you have no
recollection of it i imagine in the same
way that
i i don't know because one would have to
say that that is the same person across
the rooms across home and across
work so one would have to say that's the
same person and if we can say that then
we could say
so the question is does one experience
when one is dead in some other realm or
or when one is sleeping and i would say
that the answer is we don't know
one could just not have memory to it
it's like there's this bucket of memory
that we pull into that when we're
talking to one another we luckily have
access to this we some have access to it
better than others but luckily we can
luckily when we're talking right now
it's like we're injecting into this
bucket and later we can pull out some of
it
so then if i was to go into a place or
you were to go into a place or one was
to go into a place where they didn't
have access to this bucket does that
mean that they weren't there well we
have no evidence it's that it's actually
just we don't know and we assume well no
but we don't know
so i mean what's your bar for knowledge
that's a ques we don't know
perfectly maybe to 100 certainty but
i think
my bar for saying i know something is
not that
it's um
it's it's
and
it's it's known with perfect confidence
right like to
to know something with 99 confidence is
to me maybe the best we can ever get
about almost anything
um
unless you're bill nye or neil degrasse
tyson who says they they believe with
99.999 percent certainty that so-and-so
are not anything more than a terrain
explanation
for the uaps oh for the ufps yeah well
and by the way my
remark to them is all right hey do you
want to play that game i will put down a
thousand dollars then then you can put
down
nine million dollars and that'll still
be a great bet for you you feel like the
odds are still in your favor okay that
uips are not extraterrestrials right so
they're they're that certain that
they're they're quotes they're
terrestrial
yeah
there are some
explanations quite some some
something that's mundane or something
mundane yeah
so i also want to ask them that that's
very strong exactly and there's some
tweets about that
bill nye and and
tyson
i i know neil a little bit is straight
it's i'm curiou i'm i'm surprised he
would be that
certain that they are from earth yeah
it also depends on well it depends on
quite
when one assigns probability that's
actually
it's difficult to assign a probability
to almost anything
my brother is a professor of statistics
and even assigning probabilities in a
paper that has to do with
medicine so something that's extremely
objective where we have replicable data
is actually it's not it's extremely
difficult let alone something where we
don't know because then one has to set
up what's called a reference class
and
it's still an unknown problem in
statistics what should be one's
reference class i spoke about this with
gary nolan so i can ask you i heard that
yeah right
i can say to the audiences the question
like when what's the probability you're
going to die tomorrow you may say well
maybe
0.02 and then i say no it's actually
99.999 because if you take as the
reference class all the beings on earth
the majority of them are dying
in the next few minutes because they're
bacterial right no i mean
you didn't go too deep into that
problem on the podcast but i thought it
was really interesting points like
so is my what's my probability of dying
today do i take
the probability of all new yorkers
and take that or is it you know let's
say
black men that are 25 years old
or
americans in general who do i leave out
of the reference i mean
it's an extremely difficult problem
which is why people who are in risk
management get paid so much because
insurance depends on it right
well it's not as if an easy interesting
question that
ensure like you know insurers can
discriminate
against
you based on certain characteristics but
not other like they can charge you
higher premiums if you're a young man
right as opposed to
but they can't you know if there were
some racial differences in car accidents
that were material enough to like get
differential premiums
you couldn't charge people different
premiums based on based on race and
ethnicity and
i i always thought that's a little
kind of underexplored
you know
phenomenal like where are the people
complaining that
they are being discriminated against by
insurance companies because
insurance insurance companies understand
that
you know young people get in far more
car accidents right it's like well [ __ ]
i didn't i can't control being young
it's like
that's a characteristic i have no
control over how come you're
discriminating against me based on
the statistical
uh average behavior of people with my
characteristics it's like we generally
understand that to be unethical except
in the universities but yeah
oh well what do you mean what do you
mean by that with the diversity and
encouragement yeah no sure
yeah but um
but anyway yeah that that's uh
there's also a problem of like what
actually is probability what what's a
probability claim when you say there's
an 80 likelihood of x happening
what actually does that mean
well it me i think
i mean i tend to think probability
claims are like epistemic claims like
for all we know it seems like there's in
you know
80 out of 100 times
we run this in theory
that would happen but it's like what
does that mean actually it's an unsolved
problem what's the probability of the
sun will come up tomorrow because one
has to then assume a philosophical
framework for probability and they're a
broadly speaking four so for the people
who are interested there's frequentist
which means this is what is done in
physics is you look at the frequency you
just take
a slew of data
and
then there are some pros and cons of
each one of these cases so one wants to
know can you make a probability for a
single case is there such a thing as a
probability for a single case right
because
if there's no can't a frequentist can't
no that's right a classicalist can
and
and a classicalist also assigns uniform
probability among
different
options which to me that's not entirely
clear
if you don't know if this weight if this
die is weighted you just assume that
it's one out of six that could just an
assumption you don't know it could be
weighted
you have no other data so they just
assume it is until more data comes in
then there's the bayesian which you
referenced
which i believe is also called the
subjective because it deals with
one's own degree of certainty and then
there's the metaphysical which is what
most people think probability is and i
think that
probability is something real yes yes
yes so a particle just has this chance
of decaying at a certain time sorry or
yeah it's yes yes a particle has this
chance
but then you get into
problems of what do you mean it has this
chance what is what is the ontological
claim here so each one of them has some
pros and cons and with the metaphysical
yes you can make a single case because
it just inherently has this probability
frequencies no classical yes
regardless then one has to say well
which
probability are you referring to when
you when you say 99.999 sure that uaps
are so and so it's it's so dubious that
i don't know how they can be so certain
because they and the reason i say
they're certain is that
there's a
level of condescension and derision that
come from the skeptics still to this day
though it's tempered and i think it's
tempered because of because of the
revelation right and the us government's
saying hey or so i think nasa themselves
say this is not any
known government that we know of yeah so
then you like what the heck you raise
your eyebrow there so it's the
government line so here's the other
thing
to me it's very unlikely
that russia or china
is holding on to the kind of technology
that would
move
that would have an aircraft that moves
in the way that
these
aircrafts do right especially since
these have been seen since the 40s so
you would have to say that they've had
someone has had this technology since
the 40s because there's a uniform
right
i think they call them observables
there's a uniform set of observables
right i mean so i can only speak to the
videos i've seen
um which are all from the past
17 years or so i think the earliest one
i saw was like from 2005 or 2004.
um
but
like why would russia or china invent
technology that's clearly
you know
very advanced in terms of how it fly i
mean it flies like nothing else we we've
created
and then just fly it over the
co like eastern seaboard frequently
for no reason
get filmed by a navy pilot
and then not do anything to us that that
like
hurts us right it's like it would
and then also not use that technology to
win the war in in ukraine whenever they
have a warrant
it doesn't make it makes very little
sense that it would be a different state
actor
and our government has strongly implied
that it's not
um
a
you know american technology
so
it's such a strength and obviously
there's nothing
like i mean life on another planet is
actually no
it's no crazier
a belief than there being life on this
planet
i mean if one chooses as a reference
class
yeah then we can say well look with some
large degree of certainty
outside of us destroying ourselves we're
going to spread intergalactically and so
let's imagine that we're not special as
science frequently tells us which i also
don't necessarily believe but
that we're not special we can get into
that if you like but that then
it would make sense that other forms of
life are visiting us
if one chooses as a reference class
ourselves and we project ourselves to
the future we got to wrap up this has
been really good
where can my listeners go if they want
to hear more about ufos consciousness
theories of everything etc
sure you can search theories of
everything on youtube my my name should
come up kurt j mungle
and if you're interested in like coleman
mentioned physics mathematics
free will god as well which we didn't
get to talk much about
and
consciousness as well as the ufos and
how they relate to that
then
then check it out and hopefully you
enjoy it
awesome thank you so much kurt
thank you man
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you